lose they're out yeah that's probably
why he was looking at that
I need this free throw BJ oh it's short
and here we go three-point game Dallas
down by three
right caught by Jones
[Applause]
Patrick Williams Patrick Williams back
in the game for the defensive purposes
I'm gonna let these guys try to finish
it out
I don't know
there's Lawson
Hill fire to tie the game no Neil aquina
tried to save it right to tie it no and
the Bulls let's go home let's go home
safely Chicago beep beep what an
exciting game Hey listen on the real
exciting game exciting game these kids
and they can't affordable they could
have folded the biggest lead Dallas had
a 15-point lead to move to the pole the
guys get his world over they did great
everybody's young kids man what a fun
game to call tonight whether they had
lost or not it was fun watching them
play it's it's a nice sign for the
younger players the Lesser used in the
rotation players to do some positive
things they certainly did credit to
White and Williams each with season
highs and points White had 11 assists
this season as well muchavich's 51st
Double-Double the Dallas Mavericks
officially eliminated from playing
contention the Bulls have already been
locked into the Tennessee we'll have an
interview with Colby white in just
moments right now Jason Kendall and Will
are in studio
[Music]
I'm sorry